what's up everybody
we are back with another saturday
morning vfx stream
this is gonna be a good one it's
actually the first time i've ever
collaborated with somebody on the stream
so we got my very good friend
casey edwards he is a very very
um talented composer and he's coming
over we're gonna make album art for him
for his very
next uh single coming out very very soon
all right so that's what we're doing
today um you know we're going to try and
make something
kind of sci-fi a little dark
it's going to be a really fun one and
i'm very excited so hopefully you guys
learned how to
work and collaborate with a client in
this one and also how to make some cool
album art if you guys are into music or
if you have a client who's trying to
make music
and you're like hey it's time to make
some album art um
i'm personally using cinema 4d but you
guys can follow along in blender
maya 3ds max whatever it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter whatever program
you use as long as you know you get
working and you get learning
and that's the whole point of this time
here
on saturday is to get together and
work and learn together right so we've
blocked out this time
to get better at our craft every single
week you got to work consistently
if you want to get better um you know a
lot of people will get into a certain
hobby
and they'll stay into it for a year but
then they'll kind of drop off
if you truly want to become a master at
something you need to consistently
practice it
so that's what i'm trying to do here for
vfx
i'm also directing is my passion as well
so i gotta get
you know i gotta do a bit more directing
next year i'm very excited for that
um but yeah casey will be here soon
um he's one wheeling over at the moment
probably um but yeah so that's the brief
overview
of what we're going with today guys i'm
very excited for this
um if you guys can hear me and see me
alright just give me a little thumbs up
um i'm amped i'm amped to do this very
very amped to do this casey's been a
friend for a very long time if you don't
know about casey
he worked on devil may cry music for he
did music for devil may cry he did music
for doom eternal
he did music for wolfenstein he did
um a lot of film scoring for my short
films
on this channel here the dead island
video
cardboard warfare 2.5 he also did
uh the floor is lava which is on rocket
jump and a lot
of corridor short films as well so casey
is very very talented he went to school
for
um you know for composing traditional
composing
and he's been a friend for a long time
so it might get goofy on the stream here
it might get goofy uh i might
i might turn into another person we'll
see what happens when casey rolls up but
i'm very excited for it
all right oh my my webcam is desaturated
that's because
i usually shoot everything in
log let me see if i can like
imagine
let me try to go blind okay that didn't
work
oh it did work wow sweet all right i
still got it
all right um yeah
all right good times everybody thank you
for joining we actually did a
well every single week we do a a weekly
challenge
and this week's weekly challenge was
christmas
so a lot of entries have been entered
this week and i'm gonna be going over
them live after the lesson with casey
um we're gonna go over them live and
i'll review them and we'll choose five
winners
um and this is actually the last stream
of the year i'm taking a break a much
needed christmas break
next week i'm posting my surface
imperfection video where i'm teaching
you guys how
to not only um use surface imperfections
but how to make them yourself
and and process them in photoshop so
that you can make your own 3d assets
i'll also be selling a pack as well um
of 25
super high quality 4k 16 bit
3d assets i think that's casey hold on
i'll be right back
uh we're doing it we're doing it live
we're live right now
yeah um i gotta you came just in time
for the uh
for the brand deal all right i'm gonna
tell you all about it
do you need water i'll live are you sure
yeah for now i'm good all right guys
casey's here
i got the special camera angle set up
have a seat son um the mic situation
you know you might just have to like
yell
yo who are we sponsored by today oh
that's a great question casey
that's a fantastic question first off
let me make sure you're up in the frame
so there you are oh yeah i got that
fresh one wheel here
yep um all right so what casey just
asked who we're sponsored to
uh or who we're sponsored by today and
guys it's skillshare
if you don't know what skillshare is
then
you've been living under a rock because
skillshare has been sponsoring
every single video well not every single
video but one video per month
since i started this whole thing um
skillshare is an online
learning community for creatives just
like you guys who are looking to up
their game in
as many different areas as possible it
doesn't matter if you're into
photography
filmography 3d music uh drawing anything
if you can look it up on skillshare
then you can learn it and you know they
offer a bunch of small bite-sized
classes for any schedule
any skill set advanced or beginner they
got you so
i want to tell you guys a little bit
more about myself um
as i show you three different courses
that i think you guys would like so
first off
for y'all who don't know me um
let's see i got you with
some ink drawing classes so i love
drawing
i've been a fan of drawing for a very
long time and this class by yuko
shimizu is a fantastic ink drawing class
she's going to guide you through the
process
of how she you know does her drawings
her ink drawings they're difficult
and you know but she's got you um
so this is a really good one also i
would have loved this when i was a kid
no seriously i remember my mom took me
to michael's and she bought me my first
like little ink pen
and i had no idea what i was doing yeah
we didn't have youtube back then i hate
to age myself that much yeah we didn't
have youtube so i just came home with
this like
ink an ink pen i had no idea what to do
this this kind of stuff would have been
awesome
absolutely yeah absolutely um and it's
like
like i said anything you guys can look
up anything you want to learn another
thing about me
i'm actually a certified yoga instructor
so bam i got you guys with some yoga
classes
i really do love yoga a whole lot and
this might
seem odd to you guys but yoga is
basically the best thing ever
and it helps me you know stay stay young
and me and casey are actually big fans
of rock climbing and yoga helps us
you know stretch it out and make it
easier to go back to the rock wall later
the next day so this is a very very
easy beginner course for you guys by
abby carver
and she's going to walk you through
different uh different yoga flows
different poses that you guys can mess
around with and try yourself
so that's uh that's a new one and then
since we got casey here we got
music up in here so anything that you
guys want to learn music related
you can learn on skillshare too so we
got sidechain compression that's so
important
it really is multiband sidechain
compression to be more specific but
sidechain compression is so useful to
take
make room for other things in your mix
well not taking away the important
aspects of like you don't have to
eq them permanently and that's the
beauty of sidechain compression getting
rid of something just for that little
bit of time
that you need to get rid of it it's so
cool that they have that up there so
so high up yeah um like it's you can get
into very specific stuff like casey's
saying right here
um but you can also go very general too
so if you're just starting out like what
program do i use they got you on
different programs
but then you know like casey said with
the side chaining they can get you on
very specific stuff too
so anything that you guys can can look
up on skillshare you can learn it
um and as a skillshare member you guys
get unlimited access to regularly
updated premium content
uh for less than nine bucks a month for
an annual subscription
it's a no-brainer so for the first
thousand people that click the link in
the description below you guys get a
free trial of skillshare premium on me
try it out it's free you can learn a
whole bunch of stuff and that's the
whole reason we're all together
so um yeah it's a good time skillshare
is awesome
that's so sick yeah good times hopefully
you guys can hear hear casey all right
um
yeah i love how i genuinely had no idea
what your sponsor was this is like the
coolest thing ever
that's great i'm glad that you're down
for it i'm glad you're down
all right so let's get the let's get the
live chat going again
well it's basically like how you can
learn anything on youtube these days
but nobody's vetting who's teaching it
to you so you don't know
the kind of information you're getting
so it's almost like a specialized
location for videos
to learn how to do things yeah yeah
really cool yeah exactly um
yeah i hear that a lot just in normal
life
let's see let's see if we can't all
right let's see we can if we can get
casey's audio going a little bit
and then we'll hop in to uh to this
album art and figure it out here so
if we get like a mic i'm gonna be
looking this way
it's like we need a mic basically like
right it's like
just get closer son all right so here's
the thing like coronavirus
right that's the thing but me in case
you don't have it
yeah no that's all i'm saying we're
tested pretty regularly within our own
friends group and we have a very small
quarantined bubble anyways
to make sure that we keep everything
under control yeah it's basically
um corridor and then casey ally and
and cliff my old roommates so we're all
kind of interested we're all
yeah yeah here scoot in screen a little
bit more get a little bit more awkward
just watch this guy sure and then also i
got that
and apologies in advance i have
something being delivered to my house
today
and also uh time to keep tabs on another
thing so my phone is kind of semi-glued
to me right here but i'm not gonna be
looking at it unless i have to
all right hopefully here give me some
levels give me some it
all right that's pretty good yeah that's
pretty good all right
so what the heck we're gonna do we're
gonna make some album art for casey here
for his new single coming out soon
um let's see what we got so far i'm
gonna open up this photoshop document of
like
looks and styles that we put together
last week
this sweater's going to go this is a one
meal sweater
did i even save the photoshop document
oh that's
that's bad i didn't even save the
photoshop document
oh the outlining we were doing yeah why
did that what
but we got the renders right we got the
render so here's what we got like
we're trying to find we're trying to get
different versions um
of you know of what this album art could
look like and that's the first thing is
like you wanna
you wanna bust out a bunch of different
versions
um to see what would look cool you know
so this is this this is the equivalent
of like um like concept art or
just a quick sketch or a previz anything
that like
isn't the final it's basically just a
quick version
to get you know casey looking at
what it could look like and you're like
oh i like that i don't like that you
know
i talked about the idea of like maybe
using this um
this like hallway this like cylindrical
corridor thing
um we ended on this v3 right here and
yeah this is a stuzzo render so that
there's a
i don't know if you guys are watching to
the to the people watching this now
the thumbnail currently of this is a
stuzor render
and casey liked that this bit of art
here
so we're using that as a reference but
once we finish it i'll update the
thumbnail
um so we ended on this we ended up like
wires with like the body
hanging and stuff um with maybe like a
wet floor
um the wet concrete and instead of just
a blank wall it's more
it has more depth to it so maybe there's
a way that we could like
do something with this wet floor
look but still have this tunnel thing
going
so maybe it like it makes me think of uh
like a train tunnel almost like a subway
tunnel
i don't know if you want to mess around
with that idea
because that kind of gets you both
you know like this kind of stuff i think
the thing that i like the most about
this
is the like endless like electronics
got it yeah got it like pipes and wires
and stuff
yeah just trying to connect it again
back to the the way the song feels
got you okay i think that sort of like
electronic dystopia
is a pretty big element in that song
especially in the sound design
all right so maybe what we do is like i
think
the background we can probably work
in second
but let's see if we can't get the
positioning of the body
can we hear a preview nope seen that one
guy on the corridor crew channel
yeah that one time a long time ago
yeah if if we do play a preview it'd be
like the first five or ten seconds
i i don't want to spoil too much of it
i'm still finessing it but the beginning
does have some of those like uh
industrial mechanical vibes
um i'll drop you a link in your discord
just in case
just in case okay yeah unless we need to
you know um oh my god that looks so it
is important i do want people to
understand a little bit of
what we're feeding off of and the
inspiration that you're you're taking
i need to i need to be able to like hook
up some uh
some audio and music to the actual
stream i hadn't figured that that out
yet but that's next year that's i don't
figure that
youtube video does it play for your
viewers
with audio i don't know we would know
pretty quickly in obs
if it was pinging it or not if not it's
not a big deal i'll send it to you just
in case
okay cool we'll just let it we'll let it
fly however it goes
um but let's try and lock down the body
position
maybe first um because there's a lot of
different ways to go about this like
we want to get something like this you
know some vibe like this
and like we could slowly shape it
you know like you would if you were
sculpting you're not gonna finish the
nose and then
finish the rest of it you're gonna kind
of block it out first so
i feel like we can probably get some
sort of block out
when you left last week to kind of
position this mannequin
in kind of like a position you're going
for yeah someone when you guys mention
the matrix
um
this is totally one of the references
was the matrix when neo gets pulled up
in the end or in the beginning of the
first the first matrix
all right what lights do we have going
for us
where
where's this light coming from
um
i'm gonna make a new back there we go so
i'm choosing a color now
and i'm gonna light oh weird that
what oh that's why i'm dumb
that's cool the way it like bounce
lights the back
you know but then edge lights the front
or the top
i think that look that can look pretty
sweet um and then you wanted wires and
stuff too like hanging from these
different wires and
mechanical parts for the legs so we're
going to try and get as far as we can on
this
album art in the stream here uh we may
not finish it but we'll get as far as we
can get
who is the band getting this album cover
just it's just me it's just casey
it's just me yeah just look him up on
spotify
here let me get you that uh let's see
casey edwards there he is bam son
casey edwards the man the myth the
legend um
you dropped barry the light earlier in
september
and it popped off devil trigger also is
a freaking hit
and yeah what have you worked on case
you did
you did uh devil may cry wolfenstein
yeah first my first job was helping mick
gordon out on killer instinct
and then i got to also work with him on
wolfenstein
and then we did a little bit of stuff on
doom together and then after all that i
finally got to work on devil may cry
for myself my first full-time video game
job on my own
it was really fun it's legit yeah and
then you've been dropping singles this
year so
this is for your next single coming out
that's what we're doing
and people will be coming in
periodically so people like i might i
might give an answer to something and
then
they might ask it again because it's
someone new you know sure
um all right so
hmm endless
an endless hallway i mean we could just
for again just
by uh
all right so you gotta change your
mapping to cubic
and we will not tile it as much
did you ever watch little v's cover and
did you like it yeah i've been watching
little v's covers since we worked on
killer instinct uh back in the day
because
he would always cover the killer
instinct stuff and then
mick ended up working with him directly
on one of the tracks it was pretty cool
all right let's see sorry i hope you
don't mind me addressing no no this is
great this is this is it
we're in all right um i'm gonna try and
get these
lights to like
get smart with positioning these lights
so i want i want to be able to see
actually instead of deleting that i'll
just
point it down like this
move it up and then i'm going to
clone it linear cloner
let's get it going all the way back
let's do
this must be what it's like when you
listen to me talk about side chaining i
have no idea
yep we're just duplicating that light
until it just goes all the way back
a whole bunch and we'll go back to the
camera so you can kind of see like
oh yeah it just kind of goes back also
guys
aspect ratio it's going to be square
because you know
so in octane you can the lock button and
then type in like
you know if if this is one this is going
to be
your um your true resolution
basically and then if i hit point five
it'll just kind of scale it down so i
can see the whole thing in here you can
move it around too
okay there's a weird shadow in the
foreground
there we go
all right so we could get um to get that
tunnel effect
just generally and get it out quickly
what we could do
is like make a
tube got that long tube preset yep
cc cc tube um and we'll hop out of
camera
and scale it up and you can use these
little
like knobs here to move it around
something just really quick um let's do
like 32 or something
oh that's like all the different amount
of polygons it takes to make the uh the
circle
yeah so you can like adjust the
rotational segments to
get it down to a triangle if you want
you know or make it really smooth
oh all right like a sphere and then i'll
do the same thing with the cloner a
linear cloner i'm going to hold alt
and i'm going to hit the little cloner
box here boom
and we'll go linear so it's going in one
direction
[Music]
um
and let's adjust
the distance something like 400
and then if you set the instance mode to
multi-instance
you should be able to save as much ram
as possible
while still being able to have a bunch
of copies
so i'll just set that to 50 and we'll go
into this
and see what it's looking like the
lighting position
isn't the best right now i might have to
move the lights that we made in this
cloner and just move
them down so that they're included in
the tubes wait why are they
going up subtly
what
that's weird are they
yeah they totally are
whoa all right so
for some reason these
these guys are like slowly
moving up i don't know why
but it's an easy fix we'll just move
them down and down in there
and then now the lights are inside oh i
got to move a little further down
and then we can just turn up the
intensity and this is just as a
as a quick preview
we can also light the the tubes
so if you make a new
new uh diffuse material in octane you
can go to a mission
and check blackbody emission and that's
going to be able to just drop on the
tube
and then those should light up
i might have to change the settings
surface brightness maybe i set that to a
thousand
maybe i re-render the scene
all right what the heck
that's not looking right at all
what your rotation is set to negative 88
degrees not 90.
please do something with surrender
casey what dog you use and what's a daw
oh uh daw stands for a digital audio
workstation
so what program do you use i use cubase
but there are many good ones i don't
think there's any one single
uh definitive audio workstation
if you do mixing for a living uh
basically just go ahead and accept pro
tools as your main because if you want
to work with somebody else they're
already going to be on what they call
the industry standard
i don't really agree with that term but
if 99
of the professional mixers out in the
world are mixing with pro tools just
accept it because if you want to ever
intern with them
or work for somebody else you're going
to need to know it however
i use cubase i don't work for somebody
else i work for myself
and it's a lot more beneficial towards
the thumb scoring or video game scoring
related stuff that i do
solid same same with uh with 3d it
doesn't really matter what program you
use
um you know like if you use blender
i know a lot of you guys use blender
which is a free program it's very
powerful it's what ian hubert uses
it's what peter uses i see
so someone says i use fl and that's
becoming quite the problem
so actually i want to talk about that
really quickly mick gordon the guy that
i used to work with you guys probably
all know him for doing
and all that other crazy good stuff he
uses three dolls to get his job done and
actually his main one
is fl studio i know some people like to
kind of trash on it a little bit because
it's geared more towards
you know the idea of teenage edm in your
bedroom on a laptop kind of thing but
it's a really powerful dog
you can do a lot with it he also uses
ableton and pro tools to get the rest of
his work done
but yeah fl studio is really powerful it
really is all in
what you can do with it yeah it's legit
it's like
the tools are what matter or i'm sorry
the tools don't matter it's what you do
with the tools
all right so we're just see if we get a
little bit of depth of field on this
just to try and get this
vibe going a little bit i don't know why
that's so sensitive
and we can hit object and we can go to
options
and uncheck the check camera option
that's very confusing
and then you can hop out of the camera
your live viewer will still be showing
your live scene oh that's cool but
you'll be able to hop out here and like
be able to like
make adjustments and so you never lose
your perspective of what you're
rendering but you can hop
you know 20 rings down the the render
and do something funky to it yeah
exactly
and then what i'm trying to do i'm
trying to bring out this character
um from the background we don't want we
want the character to be brighter than
the background
or either darker you know it just needs
to be contrast have some contrast with
the background and i think
fog will definitely help that but we're
not quite there yet because
that's getting a little detailed or
maybe it's not i don't know maybe we do
add fog and just say screw it
um so i'm bringing this light in just to
let's try and like crank it you know
and i am working in black and white
right now
to get the tones right and the contrast
right
and then we can always switch over to
color and like you know i know casey
you're talking about adding a pop of
color
to this um to this art here
but we can do that we can literally do
that like
at any point but i'm saving
i'm kind of saving it for the end just
because if i can get my tones right
then i know i know it's going to look
legit you know
yeah it makes sense a lot of times
before i even start production
i write the whole song on piano because
if it can't stand along as a song within
itself
then sound design and production is not
going to save it dude that's great i
love this
it's like the same thing yeah i think
there's a lot of crossovers in a lot of
professional industries like don't get
caught up in too much of the hype
uh or too much of the micro when you
need to be checking out the macro first
yep composition is everything a hundred
percent
all right so i'm going to add a um a lut
which is
what stands for lookup table and that is
gonna give us a color correction
to our piece here um
and it's gonna crunched it down quite a
bit there
and you can go you can go pretty crazy
with this stuff
there's some really intense ones am i am
i literally working in black and white
my saturation is at one i just don't
think there's any color in our scene i
think that's the reason
oh it's because neutral response is
checked so neutral response
it will if this is checked it won't add
any of the color data
from the response when you're like going
through all your different looks here
if it's unchecked it'll add the color
data
are those like luts exactly yeah look up
tables different
it's color correction essentially okay
um and we can always like
you know change this later but did you
have a hue or a certain like
if you were to tint it a certain hue did
you have
i think i always think about like that
david fincher
like sewer green kind of feel
this is this green or my colorblind i'm
definitely colorblind but is this green
yeah yeah no it's definitely tempting
towards that uh that light green heel
okay all right is this
is this too green yes good
all right good and you know how far we
got to go all right
um so
how far off are we i know that the
background sucks
um i know that the character body
position might need to be tweaked a
little bit
um let me ask you first thoughts on body
position and
scale of how close it is to the camera
um might be a little close
okay my only thought is i like i like
where he's at right now but it depends
on the entanglement right because if
he's being suspended by air only i would
imagine the hips being further up
like him being a little bit more flat
and then dangling from there
however if the entanglement in which he
is in has more support in his chest it
makes sense for his pelvis to be dropped
a little bit and his chest still be up
okay well then i would baste the
entanglement and the wires that we're
going to add
off of the way the body looks so
let's try and get the body in a position
that you like
and then we'll add the wires to make
that look right if that makes sense
um we can try two or three different
looks with the body
um if that if you think that will help
if we can get like a couple different
looks on it
yeah i think i'm more of a visual
so do you know do you know what you
don't like about this
slash do like about this body position i
like the suspension i think it's fine
i think the only thing i would like to
see is another version where uh the
pelvis is
a little bit more uh higher in line yeah
okay all right great so then what we'll
do here is we can
you see we have a keyframe right here um
if i
let's see if i hit shift f3
that'll go to my timeline and i can zoom
out
and if we make a keyframe on every
single one
of these bones
i should know where the make keyframe is
my keyframe button is
and that's really it's really awkward
that i don't
but i'm just going to hit the keyframe
button right here
um i should be able to is this it
no sometimes i ask the chat
if you guys know where the mate keyframe
is button let me know
um will it be under frame frame
key no
frame all it's going to come in like two
seconds
let me know let me know functions
key they said use f3
just hit f3 is this like one of those
things where you just get trolled and
your whole computer shuts down
oh god like back in pub g when you're
driving everyone's like
hit f oh god
so bad you just jump out and die
did that do it um
sounds like someone's cutting trees out
there
yeah someone's definitely cutting trees
out there that's exactly what's
happening
they can hear the chainsaw but they
can't hear me that sounds about right
it's pretty good in my life um this is a
miximo rig
we got a miximo rig going here so we're
um just
it comes set up pre-rigged and
everything i should be able to
right-click and just freaking
like add property special
remove why is the
why is this just not working
record active objects oh it's active
only
no i want to record everything not just
the active ones
oh asmr
add properties
y'all maybe you should google it dang is
you hitting you with that
hot tip god well maybe you should just
google it dude
yeah maybe i should is this it though
this is a key
i don't know we gotta we got a
skillshare video it teaches you how to
do this
create marker kind of maybe
go to current this is so sad dude
this is definitely going to happen to me
tomorrow stuff like this happens to me
privately all the time but you know in
live stream it's like anything that can
happen wrong is going to happen it's
going to happen yeah let me google it
i'll just frickin google it
how to make keyframe
in timeline editor
cinema 4d
this isn't helping
this is not helping
all right so here's what i'll do i'm
gonna say screw it
i'm gonna just copy paste
and hide these guys
what does that mean now instead of like
animating it to a different position
we're just
cloning a different body and putting it
into a different position altogether
yeah i was gonna just do it with
keyframes but it's
chill so basically the hips will move
everything
the hips have full control over the
whole body so
we're going to need to move the chest
and
and the the spine
down so i'm going to rotate these
like is this what you're going for just
like
something like that or do you still want
the hips higher like flat like they're
standing up almost
uh kind of yeah can we just bring his
pelvis up
and then this will come up like this
and then get that workout in
and then what do you want like the neck
like just freaking
actually i didn't mind where it was
maybe just the arms down a little bit
the arms like
like falling back like this or like
from here you mean like swinging down
like this
like they're like this yeah like they
would be
okay got it yeah so that would be some
shoulder action right there we'll get
into that shoulder
uh if you control click these little
plus
minus buttons here it'll open up
or close up the whole hierarchy so you
can use that to your advantage
um it's still under spine
left shoulder right shoulder all right
so we want the right
we'll start with the left arm
and we'll get this to swing back
like this almost
trying to see the bend of the elbow
facing out
i'll just solo this
and then the back one is going to go
down to
and we can switch out like the hands too
like oh there it is uh the foreground
arm is there a way to see how it's kind
of like this can we open it up just a
bit
yeah totally i feel like that would be
like a little bit more of a natural
yeah so that's going to be in the
the left arm will kind of open up a
little bit
like this and then we'll get the forearm
to do
kind of the rest of it and then the
wrist can do the rest of it you don't
want to crank it all
on one piece you want to
open up the arm from the shoulder
to the elbow and then to the the wrist
and you want that palm to kind of be
facing like that
right yeah i feel like if you're hanging
it would be
yeah i could be wrong
no no no definitely that's what the
other one's doing
the other one back there
and then i'll curl the fingers
like the other one
so that's going to be like
let's see
it was open like this just imagine like
lifeless
well if the palms up if the palm is up
like trying not to put any muscle in my
arm
yeah okay that's cool yeah i can i might
have
i just noticed i might have a lot more
bend in my fingers though because of
what i do all day
i know my let's see what my hand
actually looks like it's just
curled up crunched all right so it's
like
there's like a slight bend in all of
these fingers
um starting from the the pinky is the
most curled
and they kind of sit in together
like this
it's almost kind of crazy how much our
hands draw in naturally uh-huh
and then this left one the left one kind
of matches the pinky
oh and real quick if you hit n n will
bring up
different shading options it's kind of
hard to see with the lighting
so n d or no nc is what i want that's
going to get rid of all the lighting and
stuff you can also do nq and that'll get
rid of the textures
um so that's a really easy and quick way
to work
let's keep going
the pinky and the ring finger are are
matched
wait wait it's like the texas chainsaw
massacre dude is constantly after us
dude the opening of texas chainsaw
massacre 2 is the most hilarious horror
film i've ever seen
i forget what happens it's like uh these
like
young teens or early 20 year olds end up
driving on this bridge
and then leatherface is just on their
car like chainsawing
their car into a convertible and
simultaneously
like taking people's extremities
off classic with chains i laughed
because it's like classic 70s practical
effects
and it's like kool-aid squirting out of
his open neck goddess
those old horror movies are the best
yeah
all right so i'm just gonna like try and
get the the finger and the
the forefinger and the thumb to touch
and we're gonna bring the thumb in
just a little bit
so it's like this comes this maybe like
rotates
no that doesn't that doesn't do that
maybe it closes a little bit and then
this
closes in like this
and touch
and touches the forefinger
but it feels a bit unnatural
so i think it needs to be a gradual
shift
like this along this line based off like
my hand here
so maybe
something more like this
also we have this finger or this hand to
reference
like that
so maybe just need to open it up a
little bit more
and the forefinger
maybe have a bit it's a bit more open
perhaps
but we can always we can always come
back to that hand and get really
specific with that hand
but what about the legs
maybe a little bit more dangle okay as
if i guess the knees were the fulcrum
point
yeah totally so holding control we'll
close that up
and then we'll get to those legs here
straight up matrix right here yeah it
looks sick though
so something like this and that light is
crushing that light is like bam
um let me
let me just turn down the
the bloom it's like really intense
get that glare blur up to one
i guess point two is as far as it goes
glare amount one
i mean we can even angle it too so it's
like straight up
or we can go to the side
i think the side is fine for now it kind
of hides it
so that we have this version um
you can store the render buffer and then
hide what we just did reveal the old
version and then we can just kind of
like go back and forth between them
so we have this version and we have this
version
i kind of like this version yeah
what does the chat say so do you guys
like um a
or do you like b also we have six apps
to update
all right so do you like b or do you
like a
and we can make little tweaks and
adjustments on either one
but what do you all think
this is not helpful can you set up a
poll
a live poll is that a thing i don't know
maybe that'd be really cool is there
someone smarter than us in chat that
knows how to do anything
hey if we go a
we have to re-center it both are good
a looks more funky and not like b is too
horizontal i think
well we're going to end up putting in
more in the environment whenever we add
cabling and stuff and i think that'll
naturally move it a little bit
i don't know yeah both are good i
wouldn't be disappointed with how you do
do a straw poll is a straw poll
something you can do
you can on twitch wait is that this is
the youtubes
all right that sounds too advanced for
us man yeah i think we're just gonna
have to read
um this is pretty sweet though like i'm
i'm digging it
um once we get the wires in and then we
can get some like little techie arm bits
or something going too
i think they could be pretty sweet oh
it's a website i see
yeah it's too much work all right what
do you think casey
like maybe we do you like how this is
flat or do you want to
kind of come back to a little bit more
of that angle
this is so hard they both look so good i
do like how unnatural
that looks it almost looks a little bit
more alien abductiony
as if they're like they're being pulled
by their chest by a beam and that's it
and the other one looks as if they're
being suspended more naturally
equally across their chest and their
pelvis for sure
dang someone said they just created a
straw poll
yeah i also got to make my mind up
that's the thing this is like when
you're in your room by yourself you have
to learn how to live with these
decisions
and you can't sit on it for too long so
you want to go
all right you want to go like you say
alien abduction we can go like
super um what's that movie what's that
movie
where that kid just goes where the kid
just goes like
what is that movie you remember
what is this this is the movie where
where the horror movie and the kid's
like in class and he just goes like
i mean he smashed with his head yeah uh
hereditary yeah
yeah we can go hereditary with it and
like
turn them all like
i don't want if i want to torture his
body okay
i don't know man b makes more sense but
i think i like a
yo compositionally yo
i got an idea okay i got an idea all
right shout outs to grace girl gorilla
um let's do let's open up their plus
library and this is a texture idea okay
so we'll go to those
straight up we'll go to these guys and
we'll get a
cracked like a cracked
uh
hmm i don't know if this
okay so basically imagine if uh
let me let me
yo the poncho says big fan punisher
oh dude gotcha son gotcha big fan
um okay so basically
you do like cracks in concrete but the
cracks are gold
so it's literally like uh like this
[Applause]
like this but instead of white is
concrete
um if that makes sense yeah if it
doesn't take long to preview it i
wouldn't mind checking it out
we could even play with the colors a
little bit we'll get to that later
that's like that's a zoomed in version
that's a zoomed in like micro detail
gotcha um let's try and get
let's try and get this background
looking like something that we like
so we'll we'll work with this body for
now we'll get those wires in
we'll suspend this person up soon um
let me actually save this i think i can
store this image 2
so image 1 we can get rid of this
remove selected
remove selected
and then i'll bring back our old version
and save that just so we can reference
it so in
octane you can actually go to compare
and you can store it and it'll save it
as an image
so we can always keep coming back to it
to see if we like it or not
if we want to reference it reference it
later
so i'll store it and that's yeah we have
image one and image four
and wait why is it not
huh anyway you know i got a lot to learn
but we'll close those up for now we'll
just hide those
bring this guy back in do you hear if i
make some water real quick
go for it yeah
all right let me see if i can mock up
this
concrete material for casey real quick
oh
save your work save often
i know
you can use this all right casey what do
you want to do for this background man
like there's so many options
we played with what uh this is the third
one we had the the cool
uh cog rotation endless tunnel we had
the
sort of like room with uh an arc in it
that looked really cool
maybe what we can do like if we did
let me try this let me try to do like a
tunnel um
train tunnel
subway tunnel
and we can get like a straight on
endless
tunnel looking thing because here's the
thing is like
if there's wires and crap
already in the tunnel then it would make
sense that they're the dude will be
hanging from wires
yeah i think the only thing i don't like
about that photo are the actual tracks
yeah we don't include the tracks i'm
just saying as like a reference like we
we could base it off of something that
feels like this no i love
everything else about it because i don't
think you would find this kind of stuff
but not in a subway tunnel
dude there's also uh um
stalker tunnel
this dude oh dude this movie is so sick
yeah
it was like the endless like this
freaking grody
chunks man
you know so there's something like this
too if we wanted to do something like
that where there's like
gross stuff hanging from the ceilings
and like everything's all
grungy on the walls you could certainly
do that vibe
it's like neo yeah
and you just have to go to town on the
textures to make the textures look good
and like this could all just be
trash and mud and stuff
um but it's not as techy it's just more
grungy
you know
i think if we had to pick just one it
would be the techie
but i'd like the idea if we have time to
add a little bit of grunge to it
especially since i think those david
fincher colors already lend itself
pretty easily to some grunge some
texture
what's your graphics card model name i'm
on the quadro
rtx 6k i think
where is it yep quadro rtx 6k
which helps out a lot with these uh
render
intensive renders and whatnot all right
let me let me just
organize some stuff here real quick
um so that's our body
and this is our
let's see camera what is this
wait this is literally nothing somebody
says whatever you decide to do
speed up but that actually
makes me ask the question because i know
sometimes i get kind of slowed down when
i have somebody looking over my shoulder
too like what is the speed that you're
working at right now compared to the
speed that you work at when you're by
yourself say that again like
is me being here slowing you down
because you're trying to serve in a
vision that's not just yours
no honestly um when i work alone
i i work a bit slower i don't mind
looking things up i don't mind googling
things when i'm streaming i feel like i
need to be on
all the time so i actually will find
myself going too fast
and like glazing over things that
i wouldn't mind just like taking the
time to do myself so it's a weird blend
between the two um
[Music]
it's like when you came over to help me
out with the track that we were working
on i felt like i was having to work so
fast to keep up but i would be fixing a
lot of those things
if you weren't there yep oh sorry it
sounds bad i just gotta oh i would do
this usually if you're wrong here i'm
sorry but it sounds bad
i would fix it though yeah no i i
definitely i definitely
have that feeling for sure um
but man this this does look good i'm
like happy with the render quality we
can obviously
punch up the samples you know
all that good stuff and we'll work on
the textures and everything but right
now
i'm focused on the background we need to
figure out this dang background
okay do you like the wet
um well i guess okay if
the wet floors would be okay if it makes
sense with the background yeah i guess
you're right we need
we need to decide on our setting so do
you like the tunnel vibe
i guess going back to this stuff so we
kind of had this tunnel
like this and then this is like
hanging on black yeah i love that i love
that lighting
yeah how dramatic it is the difference
between their body
of stopping the light okay so then
let's set that up real quick then let's
try and set this up this is fake
volumetric lighting in photoshop
let's do it in c4d so what i'm gonna do
let's uncheck the check camera option
zoom out so we can see what's going on
let me
hide let me actually finish
lighting this i'm going to put my lights
and my environment
i'm going to call this i usually call
that stuff scene
and then the other stuff i like to call
geometry so i'll put all that stuff into
geo and then i got my camera chilling
here so
um yeah let's do this so to get that
look i'm gonna go ahead and hide the
tunnel
so that's actually considered lights
looks like we got a super chat yo
hope you're doing well clint i'd love
for you to work on some airplane cockpit
scene
like modeling and texturing maybe the
cockpit of an a320
an a320 i have no idea what a320 is um
but moen thank you for the super chat
much appreciated
um it always helps out and yeah i mean i
did
cardboard warfare 2.5 a long time ago
and casey actually did the music for it
um so i love airplane stuff
that sounds like fun doing a interior
cockpit scene
to set up for a green screen like that
could be a good one for next year so
thanks for the idea
saguja michael says i never like clients
to be on my shoulder nobody does
dude i think luckily clint and i know we
know each other well enough to be like
dude just
hold on hold on like this sucks dude
this sucks
i heard this story once that um there i
don't know this is true
but it was like a color correction uh
like a colorist
and he'd have clients over to adjust the
color of everything
and apparently there was a button or
like a knob
that wasn't hooked up to anything
and like he'd be like yeah yeah so you
got to move the knob really slowly
but slowly adjust it until you're happy
with it and they would like slowly
adjust it and like nothing would be
happening they're like
yeah that's good that's like
it's like the classic producer story
they just want to they just need to make
sure that they
changed something just so they can tell
their friends that they did something
yeah they need to feel like they're a
part of the creative process
yeah um they totally can be
in a not annoying way totally dude the
ho ho ho video
that's such a classic example of that if
you guys ever get a chance
watch this video
not this video what is it called santa
voice over ho ho ho
oh my god wait santa sessions dude
watch this video this is the funniest
crap
in the world okay um this is exactly
what we're talking about when like
everyone has an opinion
on on the notes all the clients they got
everyone's got notes all right this this
is going to make you your guys's day
this is so good okay back to it let's
get this thing going um
all right so this is on black we need
fog if we're gonna do anything
volumetric
unless we bust out
an octane spotlight
which i think comes with volume metrics
if i'm not mistaken
can you explain volume metrics to me
like i'm five yeah volume metrics is
basically
when the air is thick like fog outside
and you shine a light through oh
i'm not gonna hike man this all that you
read it thanks alex i appreciate the
super chat dude
uh good job so far check out the
discussing tunnel and charring
cross um grunge walls no train track
oh he's saying he's saying we should i
think
check out the oh check out the dis used
tunnel in char and cross
google it uh grunge walls no train track
charring cross
where's charring cross that sounds like
england charring cross tunnel
oh it's glasgow okay
so i guess still the uk right
huh
oh no this stuff is great yeah i love
this stuff
big fan of like this grungy tunnel stuff
i literally have like two or three art
books on
tunnels um that's no joke
okay we gotta focus i get to focus um
but thank you alex
sir alex i appreciate the super chat
very helpful much appreciated
um so volumetrics is when you have
uh the air is thick with fog or with
particulate or smoke or whatever and you
shine a light through it and something
blocks the light you're actually going
to see
the light blocked very much like this is
kind of looking almost like i was
describing i look how
how much like it immediately erases the
light passing through
yes exactly um so we're gonna make an
octane fog volume
put the dude in it
that looks really cool i know it's
almost ice cube that looks pretty
so easy to be pleased like i could have
already had like 10 album covers and i
would have been happy
like dude here what if this is the album
cover what if this is it right here
i mean honestly that looks really sick i
know
this is the point of versioning you want
to get out as many
as many looks as possible as quickly as
possible because then the client can
just go
and then they're like i want that
honestly if you could do this
and still have some sense of electronics
or tech in this scene i would not be mad
at it okay at all
okay maybe i mean it's the wires
probably the wires and like the the arm
bits and stuff yeah dude damn that's
cool yeah i think so too
it's pretty freaking sweet like i think
the vignetting is a little intense
so we can like bring that down do we do
you want to go down this path
yes okay i think we're gonna have to
take him out anyway we're
to do the wires in the tech anyway so we
might as well try and see what it looks
like here
and then if it's like this is sick then
we'll do it but if you're like nah
i really need that background we can
still do the spotlight
look you know from here too this will be
easy it's just doing
doing any sort of like background could
take a long time i think what i like
about what we have right now is that
um in a sense what what my song is about
is surrendering to a void that you don't
know
and i feel like you you don't feel the
safety of a tunnel
here if he is being suspended by any
amount of tech whatsoever you don't know
where it's coming from or why
and i like the fact that that volumetric
fog thing that we're doing is kind of
putting us in that world of a void you
don't know what's beyond or in front or
around or anything
it's really that it looks super cool
like yeah i'm not just saying that
but i like that we can justify it with
the
terms of the song that's great even
better
all right so i just took away the
vignetting we can always add it back
later in photoshop it's just
it was a little intense here in octane i
think i think
that is good um i just don't want those
hard edges those hard black edges
so we can tweak the color and everything
with the fog volume so if i go to
generate and we could take
first off to see properly in the
viewport i always hide the the octane
the fog volume in the viewport so we can
maneuver
and then if we go into the medium
click that open up absorption and
scattering
we can mess with these settings so i
think if i crank the scattering phase
i'm gonna do it before i say it because
i might be wrong
it's foggier and brighter more towards
the source of the light
so if i were to compare this i'll give
this let this render for like a couple
seconds
did somebody says maybe hibernation in a
glass chamber
i don't know why that just sounds like
the most dope album name hibernation and
a glass
hibernation and a glass chamber like
opeth's latest album
this reminds me of uh nine inch nails
ghosts
you guys remember that right i haven't
seen that album cover in a hot minute i
mean well there's different art for it
um
ah like this stuff you know
it's like super subtle um
really like filmic
like i love this this stuff so much
that one uh third one on the second row
this one looks like an xlr cable uh gaff
taped to a floor or a wall
i think that is literally that's what it
is but it looks so good
it's great yeah i look so sick dude
um sing us some acapella sneak peek i
don't sing ellie
uh you don't want to hear that
i just write the music and come up with
the melodies and ask people who know how
to sing much better than me
all right so here's a version with
this slider cranked and then here's a
version without the slider cranked i
think this with the slider cranked
so you're getting a lot of that arm i'd
probably want to like bring down that
arm it's really intense
but this is with the slider cranked down
here the scattering phase screen cranked
down and then
this version is with it cranked up i
think i like it cranked up
better but the arm is just too dark i
think there needs to be a bit more
um
like the fog volume itself would need to
be
pushed forward towards us just a little
bit
to cover up the arm of hair i'm not mad
at it but i see what you're saying
yeah um let me go back
to the fog volume also i think once we
start assigning some amount of color
to either the the lighting going through
the fog or the uh
android esque hanging dude we have it
might help with that contrast a bit
wow look at that dude that's like way
okay so basically it's an eye squinter
yeah it's like i think i see something
you take the density down
so this is that volumetric look that you
know that we're uh
looking at let me get rid of this
you can see how is like the light is uh
you know being cut off by his body
i'm step length i never know what the
step length is
the volume step length but yeah do you
like the darker version like this or did
you like the brighter
um you know encased kind of look
i'll bring the volume back to its
original place
i really like that i do too yeah yeah
that one's giving me more of an
emotional reaction
yeah and then i can shape i can shape
this too like so we can get very
specific with what parts are darker and
what parts are brighter
or more faded back into the fog so we
can get specific with that
um tech
tech so let's add the tech we want to
add the tech
do we want to do wires we want to start
with some wires maybe
oh actually sodamonte um
is a moderator not only on the discord
server but in the chat as well so thank
you
shout outs um he says the volume step
length is how long a light ray travels
before seeing
the volume properties the shorter the
length the more times the light can
bounce
usually huh okay
interesting
so do we want to try with wires yes all
right
so i had a plug-in for an earlier
version of cinema
called um
god dang it because it would this is
totally what it's used for
it's called like uh
am i gonna have to legit install
something on the stream that would be
kind of weird but maybe not i don't know
um let's see if i can find it first it
was like a
it was a it wasn't hoe rope
and it's not most blind topo wire yes
that's it dude kennedy daddy long legs
in with the save
heck yeah top of wire sun that's what
it's all about c4d plugins top of wire
here it is here it is
all right i'm going to straight up
install this
now weird man do your thing read me says
what are the camera settings like the
sensor type millimeter is there a filmic
option like in blender
yeah totally here let me let me copy
paste this and i'm gonna answer that
filmic question
because i like to make my stuff look as
uh filmic
as possible and cinematic
all right so
[Music]
let's see sorry i'm installing top of
wire real quick
bear with me give me 30 seconds to read
this
all right see program files
we're going in max on
oop wrong one plug-ins
hey are you trying to you're not really
uh i better not
okay no it's fine
i really want to we'll be good we can
get out on sunday yeah yeah
um plug-ins
okay all right i'm gonna just try this
i'm gonna try dropping top of wire in
here
i can give it the old restart
now this is good casey because now we
can we we're going to do work we're
going to do anyway with the wires and
the tech
and if you don't like it and you're like
i really need that tunnel then we'll do
the extra work and make the tunnel but
it doesn't make sense to do all the
extra work on the tunnel if you know
like oh this could be cool so we'll go
down
the path of least resistance first and
then if
we're not feeling it then we'll go down
we'll keep going you know yeah
all right so i love this samsung this is
looking slick
[Laughter]
thanks son thanks josh thanks son dude
if brett sold it thank you
son what up son t-shirt oh my god
he be living in the hills seriously dude
i want like 10 of them i know um all
right let's restart cinema
because we got that topo wire plugin
coming up hopefully it works
why do you have epic games installed lol
lol
well people people can't play games were
you gatekeeping no it's for
it's for unreal engine dude it's so i
can uh
i have epic games installed so i can
play tony hawk pro skater that's a good
one
that's a good one
all right dude mila he's the one who
uh miley error is the guy
who won second place i think or i don't
know if i did like
first second third place for
international on the contest that we did
which
was render was his the anime like the
really nice anime one
in the city oh yeah no that was so that
was like purple
dude i want a music video just like that
yeah oh it looks so good
yeah um so if you guys don't know casey
did the music for the
the render montage which freaking was so
good dude i was blown away with that
okay a couple hydro homies hydro homies
h2o bros
all right
he plays fortnite secret i've never
played fortnite but i wouldn't mind
trying it
i put too many hours into pub g and i
was like all right enough yeah
it's all about that rocket league though
dude dude rock yeah it's so fun plus if
you want to only play for six minutes
and
bounce you can play for six minutes and
bounce yep
all right moment of truth to top a wire
was it successfully installed
you know what this reminds me yes this
reminds me of
uh cliff's here what's up
rumor has it brett is working on some
sun t-shirts sons
dude sun
sun 621 a reunion in chat
heck yeah son
oh okay so top of wire is not fully
supported in r23 but it's janky
and it kind of works maybe all right i
guess
we'll see um i forgot how to freaking
use this thing man that's the issue
how the oh god let's find out i'm just
gonna play this in the background
and i'm gonna absorb oh wow
oh why is that
all right top of wire tutorials here we
go you can do crazy stuff like this
it's exactly what we're gonna do uh it's
what we're trying to do
so let's follow a freaking tutorial you
put a sphere in there
and you light it and it looks like that
cool
i feel so bad watching tutorials when
i'm supposed to be the one dealing out
the tutorials no this is great i think
watching people learn how to learn is
really important one of the best things
i learned in college wasn't really so
much so how to be a better composer it
was just how to learn
faster how to soak something in and
execute it quick i think that's what
makes the difference between pros and
amateurs
you've learned so many times you know
how to learn faster
i think that's a really important thing
to display even if it's really
uncomfortable
no that's legit speaking of that i'll
bring up my one of my favorite books of
all time
the art of learning
book the art of learning is made uh it's
by a guy who
was a a grand master uh in chess
and then he stopped playing chess and
transitioned all the things he learned
from playing chess
to tai chi and then he became the
world champion in tai chi uh
freaking crazy yeah so he he like just
basically i got it learning got quick at
learning and applied it
and i said all that stuff but missed out
on learning so let me go just go back a
little bit
i was not expecting this level of
knowledge all right so look we're just
gonna we're just gonna
mess around and it looks like we're
gonna put the bot oh
yeah yeah we'll put the body in the
whole rope
or the top of wire where is it where is
it where is it where's the body
where's my bod the bodies hit the what
we'll put that in there
it's like one nothing's wrong with me
two nothing's wrong with me
three nothing's wrong with me four
nothing's wrong with me
five nothing's wrong with me six
nothing's wrong with me
nothing's wrong with me what's wrong
with me
i'm never gonna be allowed back for
another stream no this is great
oh man okay so we want the cube
in the top of wire but we don't want the
body to turn into top of wire we want to
duplicate the body
and now now we start
adjusting things i don't know
but i want it to sag you know like i
want this stuff to sag
so let me get out of yo why'd you stop
at nine
ten nothing's wrong with me eleven
nothing's wrong with me twelve
all right so we're this is kind of like
what we're getting into
oh yeah yeah sick this is already
looking so cool
i just don't want it to be trepetto
though you know like i don't want
i got no strings to hold me down
like i just don't want it to look like
some trapeze business um i don't think
it does
okay cool are you wanting to like
literally inject some wires into this
this poor biped i can add like thicker
bits of wire what makes you think you
don't it looks like geppetto what's the
thing you're trying to avoid
i just want to better understand maybe
it's just the one on the leg maybe it's
just this one right here sound like that
you like this random one yeah it is kind
of random but i like seeing that pull
all right so here's what i'm gonna do
here's gonna do first i'm gonna take the
cube
and i say yo you know what cube don't
be affected by any of the light you're
making the scene darker
you're bringing down the vibe so i'm
gonna give an octane tag to the cube
go to visibility and take it to zero and
that
will allow all the light to filter
through
first and foremost
um i'm gonna take
the fog slider here uh under medium
let's get the scattering i'm just gonna
bring that back just the hair
to make it a little bit brighter a
little milkier
um the hand still bothers me it's so
dark
i think there's a way that we can work
on that just a little bit
okay but we'll we'll get there i think
we'll get there
i don't mind it it's fine if it's fine
if you want to
i'm just letting you know it doesn't
bother me here's the thing is like when
you squint
when you get this album down to point
one
oh yeah seriously you know you want to
be able to see
clear silhouette clear image here
yeah and right now i just see some
weirdness two
weird black little things yeah yeah ali
does this a lot my wife works in uh
feature animation at the moment and i
every time i come in she's working on
this like big 27 inch
you know touch monitor and drawing and
stuff but then i walk away and she's
like
it's like an inch and she's just staring
at it
and i'm just like oh god well that's
what you do with thumbnails too when we
make thumbnails
um you want to view it from the the
angle where
you would see it on youtube you know you
see it small you don't see a thumbnail
big
so that's a that's another quick classic
freaking tip look at it from freaking
like
0.02 and be like no that's i'm just
kidding that's too small
but that's a good idea you guys you guys
saw yeah because when someone sees this
in spotify it's not going to be this big
exactly a little more akin to what you
were just showing let's get
let's get a rope out of here for now
i might need this later um okay so what
do we want to do right now
let's mess with the wires just a bit we
can add some sag to it i think
um
[Music]
oh thickness
we can go some real fish looking looks
like he's caught up in some giant ramen
noodles
yeah some udon yeah yeah um
that's good that looks a little bit more
powerliney okay cool and we can do
we can do another version of this with
um thinner ones too so you have multiple
you have thick and thin so we could do
like
another topo wire set
and we go to the seed we want a random
seed
so it's going to be a different amount
of wires now but these wires
are going to be 0.2 centimeters
so they're thinner now so these guys you
just have a bit of like variation to it
you can also take the point count down
so you have less thin wires and then
i'm gonna work outside of the volume
so it renders faster we can always add
the volume back in let's get that let's
get the silhouette going let's get the
shape going
um maybe too many wires
too many thick wires any chunk boys
yeah me okay so
thin and thich
do a taurus around him and top a wire
i don't know what that means uh
yeah so you can adjust the cube here
i'll show you so we can go 100
and you can adjust the shape of the cube
here
and
it'll give you a different look
so it's infinite possibilities here i
think there's a way to sag these things
do you guys know how to sag these
um
oh they're saying what if the wires were
made of light yeah i saw that i don't
know i'd have to just see it
whoa what was that
oh no oh no
oh no what happened
hang on your butts ah i set it to vertex
instead of
count what does that mean it means it's
going to
draw a wire to every point on this body
[Laughter]
whoa that actually looks so weird it
looks like we knit yeah yeah
all right let's go back to random
no there's definitely too many wires i
think right now there's too many wires
that's crazy looking dude with like in
the head that's brutal
i kind of like it so you can change the
seed
and we just find one that we're like
yeah
that's not too bad 13. do you want to
take a notepad
uh and write down
13. nothing's wrong we did leave on
leave off on 13.
right thirteen all right thirteen
20 20 all right
i don't know like these are all okay
like they're not
it's not perfect yet that's not that's
not
the worst note 26
13 plus 13. um
yes guys oh thank you sebchen yeah i'm
using the rtx quadro
that's not bad 31.
so
yeah i'm digging that this looks a lot
like the album cover from
corn than nothing oh let's check it out
uh oh k-o-r-n corn that nothing
what if it's literally
i think we all right i think we are
it's not in fog he's made of wires
though that's pretty sick
it is very cool and he's facing down
he's
guys he's facing down okay yeah i don't
think jonathan davis is going to come
for us we are right
that's pretty funny yeah
thanks for that check though sometimes
you get it you got to check you never
know
this is like the reverse corn album yeah
it's the dark version
okay um this one's not bad i like this
one this is
31.
you don't you write down 31 yeah sorry i
think i already have that one yeah i do
13
26 and 31.
so i wonder if there is a way let's see
hmm
enrock cliff just spelling corn
backwards no i'd call my band carrots
and spell it with a k
carrots carrots and peas
um let me check this
thing out real quick because i know you
should be able to like
sag these wires and they're because
they're dynamic that's the thing is
these wires are dynamic and that's the
big
draw for um
for topo wire is the fact that they're
all dynamic so you can take
wind and stuff here we go
there that's what i'm looking for the
sag you want that
that sog dude curvature slider
oh you can add tension because right now
it's pulling it from zero to a negative
but there's
it's a bipolar slider
oh and then you pinch them this is what
we need
that's what we need those are the
settings i was missing out on
transform just disappear
let's try it again
why why you do this to me uh
maybe if we instead of a giant freaking
sphere
it's just a point oh wait hold on
let me hide that um
why is that hidden
uh
complex topology probably
why is this so if we
let's see
essentially just make it come from like
a no that doesn't work
we this needs to be scaled up
it's pretty intense from the neck yeah i
like it
yeah it's pretty cool um
why is it just disappearing when i bring
down that curvature is it because
there's not enough
points
i don't get it
so we can also like sag it like this too
you know like drop them down a bit more
any thoughts on this vibe right here if
we bring the fog back in
and we make
the fog or we make the wires
made of light
that looks so weird
i don't know if i like that it's kind of
confusing yeah i think i would prefer
them to be solid
so here's the thing you see all the
wires are moving forward towards the
camera
i think we need to move it so that
they're kind of going back we don't want
the wires to be super dark
you know so they're falling off right
into the background
and then we can take the volume
and open it up just a bit
so it's a bit thicker
i'm going to need some naan with that
sag
is that what someone said yeah i need
some naan with that side
dude seriously man i gotta go down the
sog paneer and some garlic naan right
now
so good mango chutney oh
so good
it's like they're almost pressed it's
like he's pressed up against glass or
something
you know
and we could take the body
[Music]
and rotate all of this just a bit so
it's like
oh no closet debo passed away deebo
yeah i didn't know that that's sad
wait is deebo from uh friday
yeah what bike oh you know man that the
beach cruiser
oh that bike he just launches it
dang we gotta watch friday now dude yeah
dang
that's sad i saw someone post that clip
the other day on twitter i guess now i
know why
that sucks
um all right casey how are we
looking how are we feeling what do we
need
do we need less wires is it too
i'm fine with the wire count i don't
know why that's
or do we need to like make them not as
thick
i think if we were gonna do do we have
it mixed up like you said like some
thick some thin
not yet
so if we did the thick ones here okay
um if we did a 50 count
see i want to get rid of that this line
right here which you can always do in
photoshop too
you can get in there and like get the
specifics does top of wire let you grab
a specific layer no it does not it's
kind of just like messing around
so this is something that like you can
mess around with endlessly is getting
these wires right and that might be
something that we do
you know on our own time or maybe we do
it here if this is all that needs to be
done
but let's try and get some thin wires
going too
okay
so those thin ones might be too thin
we can move the thin ones like way down
i would like to see a little bit more of
the
absence of light underneath him kind of
like in your photoshop got it
yeah okay i guess more make it more
volumetric
yeah well i think it's because the
bounce light i might have a floor i have
this floor and it's bouncing light back
up
so i'll turn that off i see dude even
that looks cool
yeah if you give it a little bit of
subsurface scattering it could look nice
too
um all right so let's let's turn the fog
back on
and let's just see where our light is
coming from because
the direction of the light could also
it looks like it's i mean turn these off
so this is the current direction of the
light coming down like this
if you top light it
whoa
that's so crazy looking dude yeah it's
like underwater
[Music]
um
dude can we just make like 20 album
covers real quick seriously
this is this is so hard so i need to
change out the ies profile
like i like the fade on this one a lot
more i like the fact that you see less
at the bottom even though i would still
like to exaggerate the
absentee of light directly underneath
the body
but that looks so cool
so you could take the thickness down to
like 50.
maybe
i'd like to see the back arm going yes
a little bit more and
there's just a million different ways to
light this you know
dang this is hard it is hard because the
other one looks really great but this
one also looks really great
maybe you get those b sides you know
yeah
how about this how about we kind of
split the difference because i i do
prefer the back light
so we can get it to something like
and we can always add a gradient on the
bottom in photoshop
too if you like that look um
let's see
let's see oh oh here's a trick here's a
fun trick guys
so if i make a null object
and i put the null object
basically inside the body and then i
select the light the octane light
and i right click and i give it a target
tag
animation tags target and then you put
the null object
as the target and the light will always
point
at that null object so wherever we move
this the light will go
and we can you know move move this
around
and it'll constantly be looking at our
subject
ah yes yes
someone said save
that looks so sick over here yeah
now we can move the camera i want to
center up the camera
what is this going on we're doing album
art yeah we're making album art for
casey's next single it's coming out soon
um yeah look him up on spotify casey
edwards
bam right here got a lot of good tracks
he did some double may cry music
um throughout the year and some singles
throughout the year
good stuff if you guys are into what
would your what would your genre be
uh i can't even most of it's rock and
stuff for the video games but for my own
stuff i have minimalistic pop
and industrial dark pop i don't know
i write a lot of classical music too i
don't really like to pigeonhole myself
too much
but spotify is definitely mostly uh rock
and pop
rock and pop rock and pop all right
let's move the
let's move everything over
yeah center it up
all right so our vignette is really
intense right now
let's get rid of highlight compression
for a second get rid of the vignette for
a second because we're kind of getting a
natural vignette with the light
but let's um
hop out here and let's get this light
blast in a bit more juice into our scene
and i might be able to mess with the fog
settings
now we're missing the body we're losing
it
it's getting worse that's why you save
iteration so you can go back
yup you can mess with this stuff
endlessly
all right let's try
saving and
yo what up chris thank you thank you so
much for the super chat i appreciate man
always appreciate the support
thanks for the help um yeah
that's that's like two or three
kombuchas right there dude thank you
evolver interactive
nice yeah he's legit
he's like super legit
too legit
all right i think it's getting worse
casey yeah i definitely like the other
lighting better
so let's see if um we can't get that
back
and if not then you know we're screwed
no we just gotta delete start over
what time does the stream go to whenever
it's done whenever
however long all right just chilling
what happened with the cracks on the
body they can emit light yeah i feel
like we'll get to that eventually
definitely yeah we're just working on
our silhouette in our lighting right now
24 hour stream now i'm good
same all right so
i feel like the framing on this isn't
right
i feel like
i feel like
if you squint
what do you think larger smaller um
left right up down when you make it
smaller because i can visualize more
album art
i mean like uh like the body the body
itself
too close to camera and take it further
away yeah look experiment with that
i don't think it needs to be closer
that's for sure i don't think it needs
to be closer really move to the right a
touch
oh too much i do want the the title of
the song
on the album art ah okay there you go
so probably gonna change your
composition up a little bit maybe a
little bit yeah um
do you want like center bottom
that'll leave up to you i think the
composition of it i'll leave up to you
and and font type
oh man you're leaving the final job with
appetite
like i feel like you know that on the
first like you you grasped the the
purpose of the genre and the way the art
style was going and then you just
plopped it in i
think i was happy with your v1 okay so
here's
what i'd be referencing there's a guy
named mount
shrine
album art and it is like this kind of
style
where it's like the if you look at the
text and super clean
yeah super clean and it's like lower
center
or top center um i
i like that style personally
you know where you have it like center
either up or down
can you look up uh bring me the horizon
album art yeah
just want to see what they do so far
literally no text
nothing huh
clean that's weird why is it angled like
that
because it's edgy i don't know it's
crazy
yeah actually just seeing a lot of
abstract stuff
um we can we can
try it you know we can actually do it in
3d too
i mean just just to have it in here we
can we can see what it looks like
so let's do
[Music]
uh mo text
motec son aloha instantly like fits into
this like complex looking render
just a giant t there now resting his
head on it
all right what you wanted to say uh
vacant surrender
yes
just wingdings um
hot papyrus
yo can we get comic sans god
all right so you see how it's busy like
it's really busy
um i don't want any
too much thickness to it um
because it looks bad i think the bottom
is the best place because i don't want
it to interrupt with the wires either
now that i see this it's either better
we would break up the words
to be in like this box like vacant
surrender or we would just do fake it
surrender yeah you could also make it
white let me give me like two seconds
depth
zero is it like a faux pas to do uh
vertical text like vacant surround or
vacant surrender
yeah yeah either that or you literally
just and you would have it
uh might be a little weird yeah i think
so we can mess with it though like this
might be something in photoshop
probably um but we can at least see
just as a quick test here what it would
look like let's just get a font that's
not it doesn't suck
what are your go-to fonts the bold font
is a good one
i like that one a lot whatever you do
don't use face your fears
i don't know what that is is that like
some like fake horror chicken scratch
so i like the smaller smaller font
and we can bring it forward
and then we could make it make it glow
dude somebody called jj jj abraham
and you want to just tone it down enough
so that
it's it just emits like enough to be
white you know especially
especially too i think if you
if you have like a vignette at the
bottom let me see if i can fake this
this is going to be
dumb it has an idea that's semi-cool but
i don't know if i want to mess with it
okay what do you think maybe the wires
come from the text
that might be a bit much we can try it
they come from underneath
or the like the wires are on top i think
i think it would be like uh
vacant the text is the puppeteer i got
you
holds the wires i don't know it might be
a bit much for me
i kind of like how they're coming out of
the void let me try this first
but the idea here is to use a plane
close to camera to give us a vignette
and if we set our
way how would this work
you need any uh
sure thanks
i mean honestly what we could do is we
could
give this plane
a
under the opacity if we go to the
opacity
we can actually give it like a a
gradient
that goes from alpha or just black to
white so opacity
and we'll do
what would it be would just be straight
up gradient
yeah and we flip it
thank you son yes
and we flip it upside down
how does this work
there it is okay so we have a gradient
going
and we just put this
we get the text like really close to
camera basically
and we get rid of all of our depth of
field because
we don't really we're not really using
it anyway so thin lens i'll just set
this to infinite
and it doesn't update because we don't
have check camera checked
so we'll do that hop back in
and then scale down the mo text
and scale up our gradient card
and i think it's too bright so
see we'll go in here go to the emission
and set it to 100 or something or
i don't know 50 0.
so kind of like this could kind of be
the vibe you know
um the only thing i don't like is it
cuts off his foot
i want to see the foot also let's hide
the plane in the viewport by clicking
this top
little stop light turn it to red
now this is where the second dude comes
in
because you might straight up be able
to get past this text problem
oh wait what
huh
there he is
i like the other body shape better same
this looks a little too table toppy
yeah just that one's a little more
dynamic yeah
i just want to get that that uh second
arm
back in so maybe what we do is we just
you know bring the body
just honestly all the geometry i can get
rid of our floor here
and we'll just move all this geometry up
just a bit
you know so we get the leg in there
i think the text is too thick
so you could come in with like um
coacher i think is a good one
you can't type it
there it is kotuta
why'd it go dark
that's weird
i don't understand
problem solving so much of
computer work is problem solving
let's try to refresh it
give it like point one thickness it
might be glitching
okay
look at this guy dude hey
visual visual that makes way more sense
he also won
the international uh
render contest his was the monk walking
through the village with like giant
snake yeah oh dude that is so
sick there's so many good renders i
think that was
i think we talked about that one quite a
bit though that was a yeah that was an
amazing
good one that was like one of my
favorites out of everything but i hope
one day i have enough budget
in my music career to hire all of you
guys to do music videos for me
so many good visuals
all right what are we feeling what are
we feeling with this right now casey
do you feel like we're missing the top
part of his body we're missing
the the silhouette of the body
a little bit like we might need to
separate some of these wires from
um
let's see let me turn off the fog for a
second compositionally do you feel like
the text has to be there or do you think
it's okay to bring a little bit of the
top wire back in if we push
everything down a little bit or do you
think that's gonna throw off
the text placement would throw off your
composition too much
you're saying bring down the geometry
everything even the text
yeah that way we don't lose that foot
because i think you're right i don't
want to lose that foot either
that's not bad
i would probably just do a different um
maybe a different font um i'd make sure
it's included in like the film grain
and that's not bad at all like that body
placement
yeah we're gonna fit the text there i do
too yeah i do too
i just wanna get the arm back in i'm
wondering if we can just take the wires
here
and move them move them over because
i'm feeling like i'm missing out on the
silhouette of the limbs
just a bit yeah that right arm's gone
pretty much completely
something like this you know what i mean
like that does not look good because of
this this wire here
yeah it was like a lasso sorry
everybody's over here hitting up visual
with those
hot compliments
i feel like we should be doing the album
cover for casey overs with the weekly
challenge free of cost yeah
i don't want to get involved in that
that sounds like a
illegal matter waiting to happen
though i'm sure you guys would all kill
it i don't have fancy uh
nvidia graphics cards to offer is a
wonderful reward
plus ever every artist deserves to get
paid for their work without value
yourself
that's true that's true
it feels weird it feels weird though
because it's like you know we did a
contest
and then we put them together into a
montage which turned into a video which
is doing so well by the way
it's like it's got it's blown up it hits
the front page of youtube
i think this is different i i've i still
done competitions today
like uh if there's something that i want
or something i want to show offer is
something i just want to
prove to myself and or practice i'll
still do competitions
but when it comes to if like if i were
to reach out to you let's say
you've never heard of me and i'm like
hey make me an album cover we're a music
video
i think the first question you should
say is uh
what's your budget yep and then if you
feel like it's worth doing it for free
for the god i hate this word exposure
or the practice for yourself then that's
for you to
determine at a personal level some
people at the highest like some of the
highest composers in the world will
spend their money
to hire orchestras it's a lot of money
but they'll do it because they really
want the job and it means a lot to them
so that personal gain is 100 up to you
to
determine but please always uh consider
yourself in your financial situation
and what you think you deserve that's
very true it's important
that's that the uh what's his name
remember remember i was like how do i
quote someone on vfx
yeah yeah mike had a great thing that i
heard a long time ago was like getting
paid 101
and he was basically just trying to
teach everybody their worth
and how to approach that conversation
without feeling awkward about it
i have it somewhere on my computer i'm
not gonna play it but like
i have that that voice clip saved
somewhere
because i was like how do i what do i
charge for this vfx job
and um i was like do you think mike
would have uh it was like casey's
mentor would you say he mentored you
there's a point in life or would you say
friend or just like colleague that you
look up to a lot i'd say it's all of
those things
anytime i have a hard-hitting question
i'll ask him he's like 15 years further
into his career than me
and he's seen and done a lot so yeah the
dude's legit and he just sent me like
instead of responding through
email he just freaking recorded himself
on his phone and sent me the voice clip
within 10 minutes and it was basically
like i listened to a while ago but it
was basically like
you have to charge the max price
especially if you don't know the person
if it's not for a friend if it's just
like someone randomly out of the blue
like
charge max price and you know
because that's what you're worth you
know um
and don't be don't be afraid to do that
if you know you can do it you can do it
and like
you're you're a specialist not a lot of
people can do what you can do so
don't be afraid to charge that price you
know that's what he was saying
god this looks pretty freaking sweet
dude yeah
i think another thing is nobody's ever
going to come back to you and be like oh
dude thank you so much for doing it for
such a cheap price before we've doubled
your rate
that's never going to happen yeah it's
like you did it for a thousand
and we know that that cost like that was
like such a hit on you
and like you gave us a deal we're gonna
give you 3 000 this time like no they're
gonna be like hey can we get that deal
again
yeah hey you did you did it last time
for this much can't you do it again
yeah yeah it's that's why even if you do
give them a discount of some sort make
sure you show it in your invoice
the full price and then you you put that
discount down on paper
that's a good one
did we just turn this into like the a
different stream
yeah dude
so the only way to get more of that arm
is to
decrease the fog thickness
but by decreasing the fog thickness
we flatten out the image
this is kind of tough um but we can try
it
so i like now we can at least see like
there's something back there yeah that
helps
yeah um
where's my fog here i'm literally
sitting on it right now
let's go in here and take
the step length it was on 4 by default
and the density if we come to 25 give
the arm its own slightly emissive
material
oh my god that sounds difficult
well that's crazy looking that doesn't
look like a person anymore
from this angle it does not look like a
person
65
oh the step length was doing that
huh
billy that's a great question so you got
your first you got your first job
through instagram but you think you
undercharged them
how do you determine your price god
that's the hardest question dude
um
well for me
i will ask friends hey what do you
charge for this what do you charge for
that what do you charge your time
i guess the first the first question is
can you do the job
to their standard can you do it and if
you can do it
then you have you have some uh
i don't know you got the ball in your
court you know because you know you can
deliver
so charge them something i don't know
it's so it's so tough to to give an
answer to that it's like what's what's
the job and what's your skill you know
i mean i did a video game earlier this
year definitely cry special edition
uh but obviously we we work with them
and charge the amount that they can pay
they're a big corporation so it's
usually a bigger budget
and then later in the year i finished up
a
puppeteered halloween short film i put
just as much effort soul and heart into
that as anything else
and that was like a 100th of that
paycheck
from the big corporation but i did it
for me
that was something that i i wanted to do
both for my own personal enjoyment and
for
something that was missing from my
portfolio that could help me maybe get
that job one day again later on
so i don't think i devalued myself
because i had the conversation with them
early on about how much it costs
to get something like that done but that
i would be willing to do it for x amount
of dollars because of what it meant to
me personally
yeah it's like there's the difference
between a passion project
and a job not to say that you know the
big job you got was
just a job it was still super fun you
learn a lot
but yeah there's a difference it's like
would you do this for less
if they're gonna try and charge you less
because they know you're gonna be
passionate about it that's gonna
that sucks like then they'll be taking
advantage of you yeah
um but if they're like dude honestly
this is all i have
like this is the most i can pay you um
and we're friends
and here you go like you know
and that's a personal thing you know are
you gonna have fun you're gonna learn a
lot what can you
take away from it all that good stuff
lots of questions to be answered
how is it going to represent you when
you're done with it
if you're doing it just for money and
you hate the project and it looks bad
and your name's on it
kind of wasn't even worth the uh one one
fraction of the the cost you would have
charged
absolutely 100
all right so you're not really seeing
these thin wires from this tiny angle
maybe maybe once we get like a full
render of it we will
but another a quicker way to do this
actually is to go like
200 by 200
and set this back to one
unlock it hop back in
so that's full size 200 pixels by 200
pixels
and it's still gonna take a minute to
wait that's 250 that's 2500 samples why
is this so noisy
is casey paying you in free refills
no we barter we trade we trade back and
forth yeah
yeah casey helped me out with the music
for some stuff i help him out with some
art on some stuff
and you know we know each other pretty
well so it goes back and forth
was i supposed to say that yeah i think
we both told each other yes and no in
the past yeah
it's fine sometimes you got the time
sometimes you don't
all right casey what do we do uh
i think at this point maybe we can just
play around with color a little bit okay
right yeah i mean we can also add like a
robot arm or a robot leg
oh yeah i was going to ask you about
that earlier how much effort you wanted
to put into the
androiding esque idea i like it already
but i think it would be cool to try
so we could
i mean all we're looking for is like
silhouettes so
maybe let's mess with color first okay
yeah let's mess with with
color first uh man
i assume devil may cry bucks will be a
lot more dull than a personal passion
box
yeah it depends it really depends
all right um
let's try color let's try getting our
color down and then we can do
um let me see here
do we want to keep this like this
character of ours like
android cream colored like ex
machina white kind of deal well
as soon as you add if you if you throw a
white texture on this
on this dude
it's gonna kind of take away from the
silhouette
just just a bit or it could versus if
you give them a black
texture if we just go straight to black
let me figure out why it's very grainy
so the fog will make things
very grainy i want to see if i can get a
look
quickly so we're going to try
500 samples but we're going to add the
denoiser so in the camera tag
under camera imager you can check the
denoiser
and switch to the denoised view
maybe at the re-render
why isn't that denoised i don't know
i wonder if it's this text
is causing a lot of
why is it still adding the text
sometimes octane just glitches you know
take the d-noise volume
i did oh do you know his volumes
did everybody take technique noise take
d-noise take d-noise
take d-noise volcom's
may i have to probably mess with the
samples
can't wait for the chat reaction to all
those noises
yeah i'm going to render this render
this at like a million samples
um so you're not going to see all this
in here
i feel like i feel like the noise just
started it just came out of nowhere
didn't it
you feel that way
all right anyway anyway color all right
we want to work on color how do you want
to add color to this
we add color with the color light
already on top
well there's a color there's color
correction where you can change the
color of
the overall look and color correct it
right yeah
um and then there's color in the scene
so if we were to do color correction
like then we would just be messing with
you know different let me make sure let
me actually save
a new version
so we're on
what the heck
add the volume resistance that should
solve it
add volume resistance what is that
volume resistance
i don't know what that is we'll see if
they come back with some hot tips
they probably will okay but yeah color
wise casey we can just go through these
different luts and like
figure out which one which one you like
um
so i'm just tabbing through
and i can always change the like the the
saturation and the contrast and stuff
okay if you just like a certain color
um two seconds
billy uh says what feeling do you want
to convey maybe it will help you with
the color choice
uh most of the song is industrial rock
metal cold sort of centered around the
idea of being lifeless
which is where we got the suspended
figure from so that's kind of the vibe
we're going for industrial tech
death i mean you could i like i like how
this saves our contrast
it you know it gives us some allows us
to see all of the parts
and then um we could add a cool
leg a little bit you know or you can go
with that
greenish that
cool it's like mixed with
it's like both you know
purple
blue would be opposite of blue is orange
right
yeah it's looking a little purpley right
now that is very blue
that's super blue spring on saturation
i mean that's subtle it's going to be
done in photoshop too but like that's
super subtle
can i see it with a little bit more of
that david fincher green
yes that'd be like
let me just go ma let me max it out i
usually like to max out my colors
so i know where i'm at
i think maybe a little bit more to the
right oh wait never mind
you know so i get the color right and
then i desaturate
that's pretty chill that's definitely
that green tone
that like uh what was the movie we're
looking at early the radioactive like
tunnel
oh um stalker yeah that's the kind of
vibe that i get
yeah i'm looking at this color i don't
know if that's accurate to their color
but
industrial tech dot dot death
yeah i was trying not to sound too emo
when i said that i don't think i did a
good job
reminds me of the album cover for nine
inch nails with teeth
with is that the name of the album
type in an nin teeth
get them canine canine teeth
i'm not seeing teeth with teeth that's
nice
yeah it's kind of got that what does
that call photo burn
where it goes like from copper to like
deep blue green to
as just whatever you know it's like uh
a film film streaks film fade kind of
stuff we can add that's we can add all
that stuff in photoshop
um but yeah i know that this is this is
a vibe i don't know if you're feeling
this
at all i am you are yeah sweet so
other than this what should we do
i don't know this is another photoshop
thing i i would like to see a little bit
more of that absentee of light
yeah okay so i think underneath we could
certainly do that in photoshop
um to get that
look no it is possible though in c4d
so we could save this as a version and
mess around
with that absentee of light so i think
what i'm gonna do
here is let's zoom in
and maybe this isn't for for today i
think the only other question i would
ask you
uh is what is one other tech element we
could add to this without ruining it
um like this this leg could be a robotic
leg same for the arm um
i think that could look kind of cool
okay
um i don't have to be going too far
but the leg is kind of the first thing
you see yeah i think it'd be pretty
subtle
you know you drew up like the being
connected by like a single rod in the
center i think that was pretty subtle
um oh you're talking about you're
talking about uh
like this yeah yeah i like that yeah
okay it's not too on the nose
got you so real quick what was i going
to do
before i did robot leg i was gonna do
something else the light okay
so yeah let's do
let's try and get this what
i love that that was the uh youtube
algorithm
oh so that's funny
i think it's always getting sucked up by
a vacuum cleaner well it's like in a
spaceball spaceballs yeah
i was literally thinking that same thing
all right so the light i think maybe
instead of a
ies light which is a light profile that
makes it look like a
kind of like a spotlight or display
light well let's
this guy says make it uh no sorry i'm
reading one thing uh
like if one limb would be half ripped
off and cables coming out
that might be a bit you lose the
silhouette then yeah you know
it's i like the idea but i think it's
those kind of ideas might start to lose
themselves in the composition we've
already set up
for sure so i'm gonna move this way up
like way way up what is it we're moving
the light okay
so it's pointing right down i'll turn it
on
zoom me in
that's so crazy looking dude yeah it's
pretty insane
and i'm gonna change it from i'll just
change it to a normal light
casey what daw do you use i've been
really fascinated with ableton for the
past year now i use
cubase uh but ableton is also a very
very good daw
so yeah if it works for you man just
keep using it
whoa that looks intense you can't even
see anything
i know but you can a little bit barely i
think that's what i like about it
oh dude what is that it looks underwater
yeah it does
um you know what it reminds me of
it reminds me of uh let's see i have
pictures internet inspiration
it's in here somewhere
let me see if i can slap this this
oh i love that color scheme that color
yep that is sick
yeah i don't need it to be so grungy
like the the spot the splotchiness of it
yeah but i love the color
yeah i think the color is super cool um
that would be a photoshop thing i think
i think that rust that rust orange is a
great complement to that
david fincher green that i keep calling
it
dude david fincher just hops into your
live stream hey he's like hey big fan
stop saying my name
[Laughter]
huh i wonder why i'm not getting
that the volumetric look
if anyone has any ideas as to why i'm
not getting that volumetric look
let me know so i'm scaling up the volume
[Music]
maybe it's the scattering or something i
don't know
add volume absorption
more absorption so if i just bring that
up
you
make this more of a point light so scale
it down
and if we get rid of the fog you know it
looks like this
and we just blast it
that looks pretty cool too yeah but with
the fog
oh the body has a texture on it
oh that's why it's because it's on this
stuff i get it
then we'll turn the fog back on
how about some ghost in the shell type
five i think we referenced
yeah we did we did reference some ghosts
in the shell
dude that's so creepy and ghostly
looking um
we referenced also uh i i asked clint to
check out control
i haven't played the game yet but some
of the album are not almost some of the
uh
concept art for that game is really sick
shout out to uh composer martin sting
anderson
he did uh inside and a bunch of other
really good game soundtracks he's so
good
all right let me see if i can just open
up
um let's see 3d models
i should have the bosstown robot in here
somewhere
bosstown
all right that leg will not work for us
we need the
petman one
there is pangy batman pep man
pet man this is the boss town two leg
um so we can grab like
you know all this stuff it might be too
thick
but we essentially copy that am i going
to get a text from nico in a minute so
let's get out of my assets
so those are my assets
i textured the crap out of that thing it
took a long time it looked really good
though
all right let's see did you even have
joe rogan dude joe rogaine
fold him rojogan
all right i'm gonna get back to our
original light
real quick um
[Music]
leg and i've read like 20 comments about
making the
cables emissive we looked at it yeah we
tried
it wasn't the jam why did i
change all right so here's the thing
here's what i do versions
you open the previous version
um
oh no where am i saving these two
i've done that before
personal okay okay okay
so you open the previous version when it
was looking better when you didn't screw
it up
and then you go from there
i like where we're headed though i feel
like this is a really really solid
direction
yeah me too
always back
okay um let's get the leg in
cool cool
and then we need to
let's go back to full frame
all right
and we'll uncheck the check camera
option so we can hop out of the camera
and like
start adjusting some stuff so i want to
move
the anchor point of this guy up so i'm
gonna hit l
to toggle this little axis center move
it up to the top
and then now we can move it and rotate
it from this point i'm gonna get it on
the knee
which happens to just perfectly line up
like that i guess and we'll rotate it
my only concern with this robo leg is
that it's too thick
i want to see through it but we'll see
scale it down that's what i say look at
robocast
and then we'll take like this foot piece
which technically should
rotate from
here it wasn't boss town dynamics just
bought out by hyundai
hyundai wait what yeah i think i think i
think i read the other day that
time dynamics was bought out by hyundai
are you serious yeah
let me make sure i'm not making this up
maybe they bought somebody else and i'm
getting that mixed up
yeah hyundai to acquire boston dynamics
for nearly one billion dollars
what two days ago a car company
yeah i think hyundai is a japanese car
company right
hyundai's thing is korean oh they are i
think so okay
yeah the korean brand yeah you're right
makes sense and i
yeah i thought that was pretty crazy
though i didn't think they would ever
let go of that
yeah no that's insane
okay so what we need to do now is we
need to essentially get rid of this leg
on the person so we're going to use that
with a bull
object i think is the way to do it
wouldn't we keep the foot
and get rid of the shin are you saying a
human foot yeah
we could not like how you had it in your
thing i like the idea of a human foot
still
and then we just get rid of like knee to
ankle yeah we can do
we can try different versions quickly um
bullet bullet is that like boolean
mm-hmm
yep just like that oh i wonder if it
means the same thing as it means in
programming
you're using something to cut something
out essentially
i guess that makes sense and in
programming uh zero is uh false and one
is true boolean is
meant to be a zero one binary true or
false statement
so we're going to use the cube to cut
out
the leg so wherever the cube is there
will be
no leg makes sense yeah if cube is here
equals one cut yeah i could see that
being the same thing yeah same program
there you go thanks
it's been a while i go by zach
all right so we're going to take
grabbing that dinner f g
dude you need to get you a little side
chat hi man i do
man you should get kim in here one day i
think that'd be hilarious i don't know
she'd enjoy
that probably not that's why i think it
was hilarious yeah
this is so much better with two people
oh my god dude
it's like i have someone to talk to i
don't feel like i'm talking to myself
um it helps to have you like reading
chat stuff too
yeah i i'm doing my first live stream
tomorrow and i've done a few test live
streams and it's like
i'm literally in a room just yelling at
myself in my computer and
yeah it feels weird i'm excited oh yeah
so casey
you are streaming uh tomorrow
what time uh 1 p.m pacific standard time
i'm gonna be talking about uh music
production and mostly going over some of
the stuff that i did for the devil may
cry franchise
um and that is on your youtube channel
youtube.com casey edwards yeah boy
um that'll be tomorrow one sweet
heck i'm gonna tune in for it you guys
should too if you're looking into uh
music production and all that good all
that good stuff
all right that looks like a cast that
definitely looks like a cast
so if we hide the robo leg
that's what we get that's pretty sick
so what we could actually do oh i know
we could do
we use top of wire we use top of wire to
get up in there
so we'll do linear topo wire
and we'll say
let's do uh
so that point let's see if we can make a
cube here
scale away the head down
bring it out of the null so we have a
cube sitting
right here at the base and then we want
to duplicate this
cube put it up in his knee hold ctrl put
it up in the knee
so that's the spawn points essentially
of where the wires are going to come out
of
and then what we can do is
select both of those make a top of wire
i'm holding a
hitting shift c and that'll allow you to
look up anything in cinema 4d
double click that put them in there
let's hide the other wires just so we
can like get a better sense of what's
going on
and we can scale up uh let's also hide
the bones
let's do yeah let's hide all that stuff
i'm gonna scale up the leg one here
and same for the ankle
and then all we really need to do
actually if we put
let's give it a shot let's just take
this down to 20.
we do need to move it up so i'm going to
move this a little further up into the
leg
and i'll move this cube further into the
foot
and i'm gonna set these to
linear so it's just drawing a straight
line
and number what is
number
let's adjust i think we got to go real
subtle with this
so you can literally set that to like
the minimum amount
of when we start seeing things
and we'll use render region
to speed up this process
like that's kind of starting
a little bit yeah especially since you
have like one cross segment starting to
help
yeah and then attachment points we could
take
the
whoa
you can just open that up a little bit
like robocankles ankles
um thickness we can make
udon legs dude we'll set the 0.5
and we can also adjust
so it gets like skinnier at the base
towards the ankle
yeah yeah i like that
yeah is there a way to make it to where
also the attachment gets thinner
oh wait no it's doing
it's a mix of white of of thin it still
looks good
um what about like bringing it to where
the knee is attached to the outside like
it is but instead of being attached to
the outside of the ankle it's attached
to the inside
of the ankle almost like it goes from
exterior to bone
what do you mean like see how it's wide
up here yeah
is there a way to make it attach to the
middle down here
oh like you want it to be skinnier yeah
um
i like it wide at the knee but you scale
that down
yeah i like that so much better already
that's perfect
yeah and like it's just messing with
messing with uh the different iterations
and different versions and stuff
i like that already so much better just
that little bit of angle
so do you want to keep you want to try
adding more wires
we can try but it's not too far off i
don't think
okay so yeah too many it's just yeah you
lose it yeah
like that you know um
so you could also do this to
the arm if you want as well um but let's
do
let's bring our other wires back in
all right let's fight with billy billy
says maybe the waist area could be
mechanic instead of the leg
or more in the middle part perhaps the
thigh the composition feels a little
bottom heavy
i like it well
i'm kind of losing these wires here i'm
kind of losing the fact that that leg is
covered in wires because there's already
a bunch of wires
up in here already so i'm wondering if
we can take the thick wires and just
move them
up a little bit
to make it more obvious that there's
that those are wires on the leg
you know
i wonder if the hanging wires would
benefit from an interpolation other than
akema
maybe something less curvy
i like the curvy wires though yeah me
too
see that just looks like a foot like
it's just like a black dot
you know yeah
i feel like we're at the the five
percent part where you've got like 95 of
something you're happy with yeah you're
just trying to figure out what that
final five percent spices
exactly yeah exactly
maybe it's this leg maybe it's the back
leg we need to do
yeah maybe it is floating out a little
bit more of uh
negative space like it feels ready you
know
um
what was that no object for i don't
remember it's gone
yeah we could do we could do this one
yeah we could do this leg
and we just put the
the bowl over here instead
you know so you have have that euclid
what's up dude thank you for the super
chat much appreciated
i've been a fan for a while just want to
say what's up your older videos what
inspired me to do 3d and now i've been
working
in triple a games for five years now
dude that's awesome
heck yeah that's great man
that's awesome man um congrats that
makes me really happy dude um thanks for
watching thanks for hanging out thanks
for uh
for the super chat and everything it
really helps it's very you know the
streams take
a lot it may not look like it but
you know there's a lot of work that goes
into it and stuff and you know working
on a saturday and everything but it's
fun this is actually a really chill
really chill time i'm glad you're here
casey yeah thanks for letting me come
over
dude heck yeah this is way more fun not
that it's not fun
without casey because i also enjoy that
oh oh boy oh close one
um maybe we do this i think we got to do
this
manually dude i think we got a straight
up just come in here with some freaking
uh cylinders and
and just make it work so it's so funny i
keep telling you this i'm so easy to
please as soon as i see that giant
cylinder pop into the very front of the
camera oh it looks so sick
it's just like a random shape sitting in
some fog
it's a good thing i don't make movies
and you just gotta freaking like bust
these guys out like
all right so let's get let's get this
back up to one
and then we'll get the render region in
a second once that
does its thing
oh billy says thank you guys for the
company in this lockdown period
absolutely man yeah i think we could all
use a little bit of
company during lockdown
i already sit in a room by myself all
day
all right so yeah i think i think we
just need to like
two people have said this now uh maybe
rotate the cube so it cuts aligned to
the shin and not the z
axis
i think they're uh yeah rotate it yeah
yeah yeah
i'm just reading stuff you don't have to
do anything like that
basically um and then yeah these
cylinders basically would just be like
pipes and stuff um
as and it doesn't even be 3d it's just
silhouette we're going for so it's like
two pieces there you know
yeah um
where is super chat where's superchat
it's on the bottom there's a little
money sign
you click that and then you can